[Music]
[Music]
ah
it's pretty cool it's really clear and
immersive he feels like you're really
there
I love picking up small dinos they're
really cute toss them and see em grows
really awesome they being in the jungle
just watching everything y'all was
really amazing to be there Rufus
life-sized creatures running past me
living out their lives doing their
ecosystem it was awesome to be able to
interact further awesome
see them react
different than anything I've experienced
are related so it was really awesome
definitely feeding Dodos because that's
something you just can't do anywhere
else speeding them by hand watching them
eat drop on the ground that's that's it
like embedded a future and being able to
be
I think the fact that arc always has
kind of sci-fi aspect works really well
with the aesthetic you've given
I think that's something that's very
distinct about our kiddin I think that
Jessie and I love this guys carry on
this hand I frankly has been abroad in
the leech I thought franchise make it a
stronger brand beyond just survivor game
so keep it up you could do it
you